hi I'm Brendan Fraser and this is how I
became Charlie
[Music]
you're an amazing person Ellie
I couldn't ask for a more incredible
daughter
are you actually trying to parent me
right now
who would win
word went out the Darren Aronofsky
wanted to make a movie I met Darren he
didn't know if or not he was going to or
could make the whale because he needed
to find an actor to
at the park he had already conducted a
pretty exhaustive 10-year search the the
project had gone through
I think three maybe four different sets
of producers and he was producing in one
point directors but
that was because
of the challenge of creating Charlie
Darren was going to create Charlie using
tried and true makeup costume and
wardrobe Adrian Moreau is the Creator
and makeup artist Charlie is a man who
lives with obesity his body is hundreds
and hundreds of pounds and to play the
part meant that all the apparatus all of
the makeup all of the applications
had to
be as authentic
and and true to The Human Experience of
living with obesity
or as near as
possible as to get to that reality
um so processes of like you know digital
scanning printing molds keeping
consistency in
um
the applications
all had been mandated to have The
Obedience of gravity and physics this
was not going to be a repeat of what
we'd seen in movies
for years and I watched a lot of them
um if ever there was an actor or actress
in a weight gain costume I wanted hey we
we paid attention to it and one thing
that was consistent about
you know whatever the intentions were
whether it was a pejorative joke or a a
an unfair mean statement about a
character creating them
to inhabit that body we were not going
to do that we
firmly believed that
the audience will buy into the reality
of who this is as long as the actor does
as long as the
the makeup and the look are authentic
and
as long as you don't notice where the
seams are
there was no CGI treatment well that's
not true there's you know maybe there's
a little cure put on maybe the fabric
acted up a little bit on one morning it
was in its own movie you know but you
know we'd smooth that out so it didn't
take your eye away from the neurology
that we all share that can pick out the
details of you know what's false and
what isn't I mean that's part of the
magic of movies anyway but all of that
technology and all of that support went
into creating Charlie who is at Essence
he's a man he's a father he's a teacher
he is a lover he is
he's well read he is infinitely human
he's flawed
I don't have to be angry at the whole
world
you can just be angry at me Charlie's a
man who lives a certain regrets
for his actions he he fell in love
and it wasn't a decision that he made he
was a married man with a child who fell
in love with a man he tragically left
that relationship with the mother
and his daughter
to pursue that relationship as fraught
as that was those are the life choices
that he made and when we meet him we're
seeing what the Fallout with
consequences are of that life choice you
know whatever
whatever you think about that doesn't
matter because this is the reality of
who he is he's in his own way he's true
to himself
but because he weighs hundreds and
hundreds of pounds and his health is is
compromised as it is
he realizes all at once everything he's
been pushing aside about not getting
medical assistance by not changing his
eating habits all of that comes to a
head when he finally realizes he has
mere days to live and he laments that he
has not
made it right with his daughter and
the Salvation that he um
aspires to can only be attained if he's
able
to apologize to her in a meaningful way
if that is even possible and and that's
that's the obstacle and you know there's
no villain in this film really you know
what you can't throw me away like I'm a
piece of garbage and then suddenly just
want to be my dad eight years later
you left me for your boyfriend it's that
simple
Sadie has a prescient remarkable ability
as an actress and I I had a front row
seat through to watch this young woman
come of age and we're going to be seeing
clearly a lot more of her as well we
should she's she's that scary talented I
believe that with all my being all my
heart she could have fallen into the
Trope of playing an angsty teenager a
rebellious young person who is out set
the world on fire but at heart she's a
very hurt sad
little girl still and that manifests in
her focused rage that she has for her
father and the facility that sh that
Sadie has with playing that is is
eye-opening and remarkable hongchao
again firmly established in her
professional life and with obvious good
reason she has an innate ability that I
saw to make everything that she does as
a character authentic I mean
unbelievable even more so in between the
lines she can say more I think in the
silences and the pauses and what you're
given as an actor to speak is dialogue
um I I I I think it was a film that was
made during the time of covid
um when we all felt clearly under
existential threat in our own way
um
and strangely for
what it's worth it somehow brought us
all closer together which is important
in telling a story that's a chamber
piece really
an adapted screenplay from a stage play
by the writer himself to
um maintain that that that intimacy
of five people in search of Salvation
and we don't know if they're going to
get it
for the last gasp
she saved him
she wasn't trying to hurt her
she was trying to help her I became a
Christian to uh
Charlie's costume and body pretty
quickly and when I wasn't wearing it I
would feel almost an undulating sense of
kind of a quasi-vertigo or something I
don't know what it was but I think it
was a signal to my body that a body that
carries the weight that that does
requires you to be strong in ways that
you're not ready for and it gave me more
profound respect for people who do live
with obesity the realization that I had
in playing the role was was was not
because of anything that I was wearing
or was
encumbered by that was all helpful to
tell the story
I think it just came from seeing the
final uh film alone in a screening room
you know months and months and months
after we'd finished and feeling like I
was watching something that I
intellectually knew about but I I was
seeing a completely
different character
um but still being able to recognize I
guess myself in that as much as I wanted
to lose myself in in the role I think I
realized that you
you need to forget everything that
surrounds it and just play the part as a
man as a person
people are incapable
of not caring
people are amazing
Charlie's Charlie's white whale gray
white whale
is his Redemption is his need to
reconnect with his daughter and we don't
know if he's going to succeed or not he
doesn't know if he's going to succeed or
not that's that's it we all have our
whale that we're we're striving to get
just the same way as was done in in Moby
Dick the literary references are
important even so in title it's a litmus
test of sorts for the beliefs that we
may hold about people who live with
obesity in
the sense that it's not a pejorative
joke
it's not it's a literary reference and
and a noble one at the same time and
again he is an English teacher he's he's
an educator he
he teaches his kids his students with
the camera turned off because he wants
to preserve them from his own sense of
Shame which is really moving to me which
is really sad for him but he implores
them to do and say something honest be
authentic but he he can't get that from
them until he shares himself with them
as he is you were the one who had to
identify his body all bloated he
wouldn't let me
I wasn't family
first and foremost he's a person he's a
human being we're all human being and
this is a movie that can in my firm
opinion we can change the culture
surrounding
how we describe or refer to people who
live with obesity it's
let's call it what it is it's it's
Prejudice it's bigotry it is the last
domain of accepted casual Prejudice in
how we describe and speak of the issue
and and the people who live with it
that's unfair and I believe that
by
showing an audience those views that
they may abide or participate in
or ignore
or The Story begins I challenge you to
not reorient the way that you thought
about that by stories and I hope we can
change hearts and Minds
and even more so for having had worked
with the Obesity Action Coalition when
this is a support group of tens and
thousands of people strong providing
and counseling
with regard to eating disorders
mental health issues medical referrals
for bariatric procedures I spoke to
probably 10 or 15 people who gave me
their story vulnerably told me about
everything from when they were very
small and were spoken to
sadly vindictively in how that affected
their sense of confidence and how they
grew
as into being adults and finding them in
a place where they're
bedridden and their very life depends on
if or not they can change the the
disease of obesity in their life maybe
with a procedure or uh changing their
habits
it doesn't matter the
point is
that they told me that this is a movie
this is a movie
they could save someone's life
taught me something very important
people
are
most people learned that way too late
you you taught me that when I was eight
thank you for that
Charlie
uh never eats for pleasure Charlie eats
dog sadly
harm himself he is the manifestation of
trauma that what he puts into his body
for all that harm that he's endured all
his life he's been derided
it's manifest on who he is as a Corporal
human being
that's a lot of pain
for this man his relationship to food
and at this point
um it's fraught
um
it is uh not for pleasure it's
challenging is the word it's not going
to be easy to watch certain sequences in
this movie but I there's nothing
gratuitous but it is important that
there isn't an authenticity an honesty
about
who he is and
how he came to the place where he is now
before his time Runs Out